♪.
>> OUR FLAGS ARE FLYING AT
HALF-STAFF IN THEIR MEMORIES, IN
ALL WHO HAVE BEEN LOST, FOR ALL
FAMILIES IMPACTED BY COVID-19.
AND WE HAVE TO REMIND EVERYONE
ARE NOT ABLE TO FULLY GATHER
PROPERLY FOR A FUNERAL OR A
MEMORIAL.
THE FLAGS WILL CONTINUE TO FLY
AT HALF-STAFF THROUGHOUT THE
DURATION OF THIS PANDEMIC.
NO FAMILY IN NEW JERSEY OR
ANYWHERE WILL BE FORGOT EN.
GRIFF: FLAGSES IN NEW JERSEY
FLYING AT HALF-STAFF PAYING
TRIBUTE TO THOSE WHO HAVE DIED
FROM COVID-19.
JILLIAN: THE VIRUS KILLED MORE
THAN 840 RESIDENTS AS 40,000
CASES ARE CONFIRMED IN THE STATE
PETE: JOINING US IS CONGRESSMAN
JEFF VAN DREW.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
GIVE US AN UPDATE.
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT
NEW JERSEY RIGHT NOW.
>> IN NEW JERSEY, NORTHERN AND
CENTRAL HALF IS REALLY A HOT
SPOT AS YOU KNOW.
THERE IS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
ACTIVITY GOING ON THERE.
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT, MY AREA,
IS A LITTLE BIT QUIETER.
THERE IS MORE SPACING TO BEGIN
WITH.
IT IS MORE RURAL, SEASHORE AND
SUBURBAN BUT WHEREVER YOU ARE,
YOU KNOW, IT IS SO IMPORTANT TO
MAINTAIN ALL THE GUIDELINES.
DO WHAT YOU’RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
LET ME REAL QUICKLY, I’M A
DENTIST CAN’T HELP BY NATURE,
WHEN WE SAY YOU NEED TO WASH
YOUR HANDS FOR 20 SECONDS YOU
REALLY DOUGH NEED TO DO THAT.
YOU NEED TO SCRUB THEM DOWN,
CREATE FRICTION, USE SOAP, HOT
WATER, MAINTAIN THE SPACING.
IF YOU DON’T MIND WEARING A
MASK, YOU’RE BETTER OFF WHEN YOU
GO OUT TO WEAR A MASK, IT IS
THAT JUST MORE SAFETY FOR OTHER
FOLKS.
SOMETHING WE LEARNED NOT ONLY IN
NEW JERSEY, BUT AROUND THE
WORLD, CERTAINLY IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND THE
PRESIDENT HAS SPOKEN ABOUT IT,
IT IS THE SIMPLE FACT THAT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN, GOOD AS IT HAS
BEEN IN CERTAIN WAYS WE NEED TO
DO BETTER AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
TALKED ABOUT THIS, INTRODUCING A
MANUFACTURING RIGHT HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE IT IN MY
DISTRICT BUT WHEREVER IT IS, WE
CAN’T JUST RELY ON CHINA FOR
EVERYTHING.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE REALLY
LEARNED.
AND I THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE
ALL THE SACRIFICE AND ALL THE --
I THINK WE MAKE SURE GOOD FOR
BID ANYTHING LIKE THIS HAPPENS
AGAIN WE DON’T HAVE TO RELY ON
ANOTHER COUNTRY.
IT IS AMAZING ALL OUR
PHARMACEUTICALS AND CERTAIN
MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND INGREDIENTS
IN OUR PHARMACEUTICALS AND OTHER
PLACES OF MANUFACTURING WE NEED
TO RELY ON ONE COUNTRY.
I DON’T WANT TO DO THAT ANYMORE.
JILLIAN: WE’RE LEARNING A LOT
THROUGH THIS,S THAT IS FOR SURE.
CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO GET BACK
TO THE FLAGS FLYING AT HALF-MAST
FOR A SECOND IF I CAN.
THAT PICTURE WE SHOWED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEGMENT, IT
SHOWS ME THE TIME WE’RE IN.
IT BRINGS OUT SADNESS, THIS
PICTURE HERE YOU THINK OF ALL
THE FAMILY MEMBERS, ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST LOVED ONES
TO THE VIRUS AND THEY CAN’T GIVE
THEM A PROPER GOOD-BYE.
THAT IS HEART WRENCH.
>> HOW DO YOU HAVE A FUNERAL?
YOU’RE NOT SUPPOSED TO HUG,
KISS, SHAKE HANDS AND TOUCH EACH
OTHER.
PEOPLE THAT ARE FRIENDS, PEOPLE
THAT CARED ABOUT THESE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS, HUMAN BEINGS SO
MUCH, WE’RE LITERALLY NOT ABLE
TO PHYSICALLY TOUCH THE WAY
HUMAN BEINGS NORMALLY DO.
WHAT I HAVE SAID IS, MAYBE WE
CAN’T PHYSICALLY TOUCH BECAUSE
OF HAVING THAT PERSONAL SPACING
THAT WE NEED.
OUR HEARTS AND OUR MINDS AND OUR
SOULS TOUCH TOGETHER.
THIS IS GOING TO BE SOMETHING
WE’LL NEVER FORGET IN OUR
LIFETIME.
WE -- MORE PEOPLE IN NEW JERSEY
ALREADY THAN IN 9/11.
THIS IS VERY DIFFICULT TIME THAT
FLAG AT HALF-MAST, THAT
REPRESENTS ALL THE PEOPLE,
WHETHER THEY ARE DOCTORS,
FIRST-RESPONDERS BUS DRIVERS,
PEOPLE WHO BEEN RESUPPLYING
FOOD, ALL THOSE PEOPLE ARE ON
THE FRONT LINE WHO ARE TAKING A
CHANCE FOR US AS WELL.
AND WILLING TO ACTUALLY AND SOME
OF THEM LOST THEIR LIFTS.
IT REPRESENTS THEM AS WELL.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN, WE’LL KEEP
YOU AND EVERYONE IN NEW JERSEY
IN OUR THOUGHTS BECAUSE YOU ARE
A FEW DAYS SOUNDS LIKE THE
OFFICIALS BEHIND NEW YORK.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON TODAY.